so I got banned from YouTube for a week
because I don't believe in a certain
very prominent modern ideology
relating to how
some people relate to other people and
to themselves and I can't but I can't
say it can't name what that is so anyway
I decided we would take a step back from
that ideology to maybe the source of
that ideology which is
feminism feminism has led to all sorts
of mistaken ideas about the way human
beings really work and ever since Norm
died I've been really longing for good
comedy these days and Bill Burr probably
the next best comic the one's still
alive so my producers assure me Bill
Burr has a lot of important things to
say about feminism this video is brought
to you by Jenny some more from them in a
bit first Mr Burr no means no that's
another one no means no it's like no it
doesn't
all right
look look no means no no that means no
all right but no stop it what are you
doing
all right
you're being so bad stop it no yeah
that's not no
that means I want to do it but I'm
afraid you're gonna judge me so I'm just
gonna make it look like it was your idea
so you don't figure out that I've
already performed this act with 40 other
people right
but then
then you go to court and you get a bad
read and there's some guy reading it uh
your honor she said no stop it what are
you doing you're being so bad
she didn't
like that
yeah that's obviously true this is why
the libs don't understand Baby It's Cold
Outside they think that Baby It's Cold
Outside is a song about rape they don't
realize that it's a song about modesty
and the Norms that used to govern the
relations between men and women so she
says oh I really can't stay Baby It's
Cold Outside it's okay well maybe I'll
just hang out for a second no no I've
gotta gotta go away
oh come on baby it's pretty cold outside
oh well okay maybe I guess I'll sit
around and because we don't have modesty
anymore and because women are told that
it's actually good to just sleep with
the first guys that you see and you know
treat sex in exactly the same way men
treat sex the the idea of modesty being
something valuable is completely missing
excellent I remember we were having
waffles my mother always made Sunday
breakfast so we had all these waffles
eggs
my brother was looking at half eaten
cube steaks and a little mound of green
bean casserole and it goes so he looked
at my mom and goes mom can I have a
waffle and she goes no you got to finish
your supper he's like well after I
finish my walk uh supper then can I have
a waffle she goes no that is your
breakfast and he goes oh Mom I'd hate
you and my dad without looking up took a
full glass of milk and threw it his face
I just we notice hilarious was my mother
just popped up and just immediately
started cleaning up and my dad just kept
eating like he didn't like no like the
roles were defined back then now the guy
has to throw the milk he has to clean it
up while telling his wife she's brave
for just sitting there like what
what I'm overrated right we went from
wait what we went from not listening to
them to now it's just it's just you know
it's just it's it's ridiculous like that
believe women it's like all of them
you know what I'm I miss I miss yeah
tougher parenting and evidence those are
the things that I miss from my childhood
evidence evidence yeah I mean do we
process right somebody says something
happened and then someone else goes well
I said it happened this way like the old
gumshoe shows and they had to figure it
out right yeah that doesn't exist now on
on social media it's right so it's just
Frontier Justice right you feel how
nervous everybody just got in here the
fact that I just suggested that there
should be due process
this guy's talking crazy man did he just
joined Isis yeah I love it and he
doesn't back away from it at all and he
does that great thing where he's still
doing a bit you know so he's giving even
Conan who's pretty liberal and it was
very good at being the straight man to
his guests but he gives Conan the out to
participate and he gives the the
audience the the out to laugh you know
I'm talking 85 80
s yeah man
he's seen a good old
dinner and I miss evidence you know
evidence was pretty good and he won't
back away from it Norm was really the
king of this of just totally leaning in
no matter how much the audience turned
he would just keep leaning in Chappelle
does it to some degree and Bill Burr
Bill Burr does it it's pretty pretty
right did you know our friends at Janu
cell have upgraded their most popular
package to feature their top selling
deep firming vitamin C serum plus Ultra
retinol moisturizer with natural retinol
alternative right now you can take
advantage of this limited time package
upgrade for 70 off why waste time and
money to go get work done to your face
when you can get genuine cell skin care
shipped right to your door geniusl
secret is a family recipe for over 20
years that makes it safe for all skin
types and perfect for both men and women
made by a compounding pharmacist in
small batches and always safe cruelty
free and natural the founder is great
Coptic Christian from Egypt came here
for the American dream go to genucel.com
knowlesyt letter y letter T try Jenny
cell's most popular package for 70 off
featuring both genuine cells Ultra
retinol and and geniusell's Firming
Serum get a complimentary spy Essentials
box with every package order plus free
upgrade to priority shipping
geniusell.com Knowles YT that is
geniusell.com Knowles y t I'm sick of
Obama's wife
this isn't some Republican rant either
it's just kind of first ladies in
general
you know I don't know what it is all
throughout my life with each presidency
like these first ladies they've just
gotten more and more like like uh like
chatty
you know
more and more chiming in like leaning
into the frame
spitting out their ideas let me guess is
this considered sexist
it is why well okay you just nodded
there lady let me ask you this all right
let's say you had a leak in your house
okay you call a plumber up he shows up
and he goes yeah I think the League's
coming from the upstairs bathroom we
need to shut it off then all of a sudden
his wife walks in who isn't a plumber
wouldn't you be like with all due
respect shut the up I need I need
plumber
In This Moment which leads you to
Michelle Obama right now she's sitting
there
holding up those hashtags from that
hashtag bring back our girls remember
that it's like it blew my mind it's like
why are you showing me that
I'm a stand-up comedian like what am I
gonna do
to get those girls back why don't you
look across the dinner table it's like
you see that guy
that is the leader of the Free World
tell them to pick up a phone
call some Navy Seals and solve it what
am I gonna do
show up with the sharpened mic standard
Michelle said to bring it back the the
funniest part about that whole bit is
that Bill Burr had to do the first part
to give himself permission to do the
second part because he opened up he goes
I don't really like Obama's wife you can
leave you guys are and that is
the joke and he could have gone straight
into it you see that stupid thing
believe all girls not believe all girls
bring our girls home yeah well that was
dumb and that was stupid she should talk
to her husband but instead he had to
give himself permission by saying look
I'm not just talking about her I'm
talking about all these first ladies and
I'm just saying I don't think the first
lady has any role in in American public
life which of course the first lady does
have a role in public life the first
lady has a lot of important roles in
diplomacy in as a figurehead in the
United States none of which is necessary
for Bill Burr's bid so I I totally go
along with his bit but the whole thing
you know I need a plumber and I get the
Plumber's wife nosing in come on get out
of here get your opinion out of here
it's all just a way to generalize this
to all first ladies in order that he can
attack Michelle Obama in particular so I
really like that part but it's I almost
wish he would just go straight he's
probably probably smarter I mean he's a
very successful comedian with a huge
mainstream following but I wish we live
at a time where he could just go out and
say like no it's just her she's just
particularly grating you know that lady
who said she was never proud of her
country and told elected her husband
president you know that lady yeah she's
actually worse than the other first
ladies and it's all right to say that
it's all right to admit it okay next one
what did you think of uh uh Hillary
Clinton at the inauguration I thought
that was for her to show up at that
inaugurations the second time that she
started crying a little bit again I just
I don't know man I don't know I get sick
of people making excuses for her she
blew it
see that nobody thinks that she blew it
you lost to a guy who said three things
a week that would torpedo anybody else's
campaign how do you do that that's like
you're playing a football game the other
team throws 20 interceptions and you
still you still figure out how to blow
it
at what point at what point do you take
responsibility they try to say they
would be like oh it was a bunch I love
the racist white guy thing a bunch of
racist white guys they came out of the
forest and they were just going trying
it's like where were all these racist
white guys the last two elections when
they could have voted against the black
guy they were fine well I don't mind the
black guy but this white lady we gotta
stop
gonna take the four-wheelers makoozie
yeah that's great that's a little more
direct than some of his other stuff he's
still kind of giving him an hat he's
like look I'm not talking about the
election and who I prefer or whatever I
just think that she blew it but he's
being a little more director where he's
just saying look the Democrat talking
points are just so stupid you know he's
really kind of making fun of them more
directly including on Conan's show
liberal host liberal audience that's
pretty good stuff I mean he's he's very
good this is no knock on Bill Burr or
Dave Chappelle or Louis CK or anybody
but I always thought it was kind of like
Norm
not everybody else but Bill Burr is
probably my my number two after Norm all
right that's it that's it great stuff
and we avoided
talking about that issue that we can't
that no one can talk about on YouTube
you can talk about it on daily wire plus
so subscribe over there you can talk
about it on Twitter on my show page M
Knowles show at Twitter you can follow
me personally on Twitter Michael J
Knowles we can talk about that issue
relating to human nature and sexuality
but we're not allowed to talk about it
here
not allowed to articulate views that
have been held by virtually every single
person who's ever lived we're not
allowed to say that here anymore maybe
maybe I could say it if I were telling
jokes about it let me know which
comedians you think we should cover next
we'll see you next time you don't know
but you've got it lady